merci serveuse de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure c'est
lutte Paris vous n'appartenez à aucun
groupe mais vous êtes écologiste on va
parler évidemment de l'actualité avec
vous d'abord Emmanuel Macron la vue dans
le journal qui a donc officialisé hier
la panthéonisation à venir de Missak
Manouchian et de son épouse Mélinée qui
l'accompagnera au Panthéon ils se sont
illustrés pendant la résistance par leur
lutte contre l'occupant allemand Missak
Manouchian militant communiste qui
entrera donc au Panthéon le 21 février
prochain 80 ans après avoir été fusillés
vous saluer cette décision d'Emmanuel
Macron bien sûr que je laisse je la
salue mais enfin c'est en même temps un
peu le
dirions-nous le en même temps de
Monsieur Macron puisque récemment il a
encadré un petit peu sa première
ministre qui a parlé du rassemblement
national comme héritier de Pétain et là
n'est-ce pas il ça donne à cette mission
je la trouve moi je la trouve parce que
finalement c'est un apatride un étranger
qui a versé son sang pour la France et
ça montre très bien qu'on n'est pas
français
seulement par le sang et qu'on a mais
par le sang versé oui il était quand
même un homme qui s'est battu pour des
et des principes humanistes
internationalistes
antiques xénophobie et aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'une figure pareil de la
célébration de cette figure mais pour
montrer que tous les étrangers dont on
parle tellement ne sont pas des
délinquants seulement et ils ont fait la
France d'aujourd'hui ça résonne avec le
débat actuel sur l'immigration pour vous
cette entrée de vie je trouve que
enfin on en a un peu assez de parler de
cette immigration qui se répète de
délinquant de gens qui ne s'intègrent
pas
des qui sont qui deviennent terroriste
etc on a besoin d'une image aussi
positive c'est que ça le discours
sur l'immigration aujourd'hui c'est
comment empêcher
les immigrés de venir en France on ferme
les frontières comment leur permettre de
mieux s'intégrer de mieux s'assimiler et
en accueillir
on aurait aimé n'est-ce pas qu'il y a
une meilleure accueil pour qu'il y ait
une meilleure intégration mais
aujourd'hui c'est que le disons le
visage négatif un visage négatif qui est
renvoyé de l'immigration vous avez vu la
catastrophe il y a quelques jours avec
ce bateau où il y avait 700 700
personnes probablement on ne connaît pas
le chiffre exact mais on sait déjà qu'il
y a 510 paru et plus de 70 morts on va
parler de ces questions tout à l'heure
avec Stéphane Besnier de TV Rennes on va
parler du reste de l'actualité puisque
ce weekend était aussi marqué par les
tensions autour du projet de lin
ferroviaire entre Lyon et Turin il y a
eu des manifestations dans les Alpes à
un projet qui doit permettre de faire
circuler des temps de fête et de
voyageurs entre la France et l'Italie
c'est une manifestation qui était
interdite pourtant il y avait des élus
Mathilde panot Éric Piol était présent
est-ce que c'est la place des élus pour
vous d'abord je me pose la question
pourquoi interdire une manifestation
pareille pour débordements soi-disant
est un droit des citoyennes et citoyens
français l'interdire ça crée plus de
problèmes que de ne pas l'interdire
puisque il y a quand même eu même
interdite il y a eu des débordements de
part et d'autre il y a eu des échafoués
et
cette blessé léger parmi les Français
on arrive plus à limiter à supprimer
c'est débordements dans n'importe quel
quelle manifestation vous voyez bien
mais en plus là c'était une
manifestation en principe d'écologie
puisque c'est
l'association les soulèvements de la
terre qui et qu'il avait organisé entre
autres associations locales et c'est
vrai que il faut encourager le fret et
il faut donc se servir du tunnel qui
existe paradoxal de la part d'écologie
de s'opposer à une manifestation qui
encourage le Fred pour désengorger les
camions des vallées des Alpes
en principe oui mais il y a déjà le
tunnel de Fréjus qui est
sous-utilisé il faut l'utiliser
davantage il faut l'exploiter davantage
et là
cette affaire du lion Turin dur depuis
30 ans c'est un projet très coûteux à
peu près 26 à 30 milliards avec cet
argent on peut
rénover les lignes de Fred qui existe
par l'Union européenne
et les lignes les lignes de train les
infrastructures qui sont quand même dans
un état dans certains endroits dans un
état quand même
piètre étape plutôt on peut utiliser ce
mot et puis là il y aura vraiment une
destruction des ressources de la
biodiversité l'assèchement de la
montagne avec le drainage qu'il y aura
pendant les forages et puis il faut se
dire aussi que c'est c'est excessivement
excessivement coûteux et en plus il y
aura la bétonnière bétonisation des
terres donc ce qu'il faut faire parce
que côté italien le projet il est déjà
il est déjà bien lancé côté français
c'est en attente ça veut dire que vous
dites
l'objectif de renoncer oui ce serait ce
serait la meilleure solution je ne vois
pas je ne vois pas d'autre aussi on veut
on a vu hier la tempête il y a quelques
jours aussi alors maintenant même les
sceptiques les climatosceptiques doivent
se rendre à l'évidence que la planète
est quand même aussi un très mauvais
état et qu'il faut qu'on la sauve ah oui
parce que renforcer le fret ça va pas
faire aider à je suis tout le
renforcement du fait ça va de soi mais
il y a le tunnel de Fréjus on n'avait
pas besoin de ce tunnel on voit aussi
qu'en Italie il y a des manifestations
d'Italiens qui viennent qui étaient
présents à la manifestation française il
faut pas avoir en tête que l'exemple de
saint-solède parce que voilà ça serait
la catastrophe tout le monde se
s'entreturé nous il faut quand même
laisser un peu libre les gens et compris
les soulèvements de la terre dont la
dissolution doit être devrait être
prononcée mercredi en Conseil des
ministres
ça n'arrivait pas comme ça
il y a il y a quand même des raisons et
on ne peut pas continuer à obéir et à
laisser faire peut-être que désobéir
peut-être pas violemment mais désobéir
c'est quand même peut-être une solution
et cette question du maintien de l'ordre
c'est un sujet que vous avez évoqué la
semaine dernière avec l'air et dont la
Défenseur des droits qui était
auditionné au Sénat par les sénateurs de
la commission des lois laquelle vous
appartenez on va voir les temps forts de
cette audition avec Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour estherben Bassa
bonjour et Alex la Défenseur des droits
a donc remis la semaine dernière son
rapport d'activité 2022 d'abord
rappelez-nous quelles sont les missions
de la Défenseur des droits oui on le
rappelle le Défenseur des droits est une
autorité administrative indépendante qui
peut être saisie par toute personne qui
estime que ses droits ou ses libertés ne
sont pas respectées alors elle a 5
domaines de compétences sur lesquels
elle peut être saisie la défense des
droits de l'enfant l'accès aux services
publics la lutte contre les
discriminations la protection des
lanceurs d'alerte et le respect de la
déontologie en matière de sécurité
notamment des forces de l'ordre c'est ce
sujet qui préoccupe beaucoup l'actuel
Défenseur des droits clairs et dons
notamment après des mois de
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites des manifestations parfois
émaillées de violences et la Défenseur
des droits a reçu 169 réclamations
dénonçant les violences de certains
policiers contre des manifestants on va
l'écouter
les réclamations portées effectivement
sur des personnes qui disent avoir été
privées de liberté d'endenas sans points
de sortie des personnes qui disent avoir
été victimes de violence des
interpellations suivies considérées par
le réclamment de garde à vue arbitraire
et la nouveauté c'est des journalistes
empêché de faire leur travail ça c'est
des réclamations nouvelles que nous
n'avions pas que nous n'avions pas avant
et dans son rapport la Défenseur des
droits estime que des droits ont été
bafoués qu'avec de telles violences de
la part de certains policiers et bien
cela peut fragiliser je cite notre
édifice démocratique alors ce discours
il n'a pas forcément plus au sénateur de
la majorité de droite au Sénat puisque
les sénateurs les républicains tiennent
un discours de soutien aux forces de
l'ordre et d'ailleurs le sénateur
apparentait LR François bonhomme a
estimé dans cette audition que l'analyse
de la Défenseur des droits n'était pas
impartial regardez ce qu'elle lui a
répondu
Monsieur Bonhomme toutes les démocraties
ont des institutions équivalentes à la
nôtre toutes toutes nous menons des
enquêtes en contradictoires et nous
entendons l'ensemble des parties donc
notre travail est tout à fait objectif
et impartial et c'est vrai je sais l'un
de vous la dit je ne vois que ce qui ne
va pas et c'est d'ailleurs l'institution
a été créée pour ça et on ne m'a pas
demandé de faire des rapports d'état des
lieux complets mais bien de rapport à
partir de ce que nous observons dans nos
réclamations pour faire un certain
nombre de recommandations voilà les
fonceurs des droits qui a donc tenu à
justifier l'utilité l'intégrité de sa
mission Esther Benbassa on l'a vu en
clair et donc elle dénonce les violences
de certaines de certains policiers elle
estime que cela met en péril notre
édifice démocratique est-ce que vous
feriez un constat aussi sévère
d'abord elle dirige une
institution indépendante elle peut
exprimer suivant les les demandes qui
sont faites les réclamations qui sont
faites elle peut arriver à une
conclusion
qui n'est pas celle de Monsieur Bonhomme
ça il faut l'accepter aussi moi je ne
suis pas d'emblée contre les forces de
l'ordre mais les forces de l'ordre
doivent aussi respecter certains
principes de défense des citoyen et ne
pas ne pas dépasser les objectifs qui
leur sont assignés mais parfois il y a
des déplacements on le sait je participe
en général pas mal de manifestations et
je vois que la violence ne baisse pas à
un moment de la part des policiers
un moment au début de l'arrivée de
Monsieur Nunez
j'ai été vraiment étonné que ça que les
choses aillent bien que les Nass
disparaissent et il y avait vraiment des
efforts qui étaient faites et qui était
fait et moi je trouve ça
exceptionnellement bien quoi je mets là
de nouveau ça recommence et puis il faut
quand même que quelqu'un comme la
Défenseur des droits disent ce qu'elle
entend voilà et moi je n'ai pas à être
pour ou contre moi je suis pour un état
de droit qui respecte c'est limite alors
selon vous qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour limiter ces violences de la part de
certains policiers est-ce qu'il faut
changer carrément la doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre ou est-ce que ça
fait partie notamment du climat de
tension extrême et des affrontements
avec les black-bocs
bien sûr qu'il y a les Black Blocs on
les voit débarquer avant on les voyait
avec les gilets jaunes arrivé par les
trottoirs et maintenant ils sont devant
les syndicats ceux qui mélange
le français la française qui milite et
qui et qui sont qui vont à ces
manifestations mais ce mélange fait que
d'autres personnes sont touchées aussi
parce que les Black Blocs sont devant
maintenant bien sûr il faut combattre le
violence des blagues blocs et ils n'ont
pas leur place dans ces manifestations
mais ils viennent perturber et écouter
il faut peut-être que la police soit
disons professionnalisé davantage à
apprendre dans d'autres pays le système
de désescalade comme en Allemagne par
exemple où il est professionnel la
police
parce qu'il y a d'autres pays qui ont
adopté quand même des méthodes de
désescalade qui permettent quand même de
dialoguer en amont avec ses forces
perturbatrices qui sont dans les
manifestations parce que ça sert à quoi
de de voilà et c'est vrai aussi que moi
je suis
très chagrinée quand je vois ceux qui
attaquent les forces de l'ordre je me
dis c'est nous tous nous sommes dérangés
par ces violences il n'y a pas seulement
ces violences ne sont pas abstraites
nous sommes là et nous en souffrons de
ces de ces violences et mais il faut
trouver maintenant des solutions parce
que comme je vous ai dit à un moment en
le nassage etc les choses c'était
calmées et les manifestations se
déroulaient dans un certain ordre
Alexandre
2022 Claridon est dénonce aussi la
qualité des services publics
que la reçue en tant que défenseur des
droits concerne l'état de nos services
publics et là encore ces conclusions
sont sévères je cite son rapport nous
constatons la déshumanisation des
services publics qui se traduit par une
dégradation des relations avec les
usagers elle ne met pas en cause
l'action des agents publics mais le
manque d'agent public conséquence de ce
manque d'agent et bien le ralentissement
des procédures par exemple le temps
qu'il faut pour renouveler sa carte
d'identité à doubler en deux ans et
selon la Défenseur des droits et bien la
dématérialisation de nos services
publics n'est pas forcément la solution
au problème alors qu'elle rappelle qu'il
y a encore 4 millions de Français qui
n'ont pas accès aux numériques et
certaines Massa vous êtes d'accord aussi
avec ce constat il y a une dégradation
de nos services publics comment on y
réponds
on accède quasiment pas directement il
faut passer par les plateformes beaucoup
de nos concitoyens surtout en zone
rurale sont dans l'électronisme
ces personnes ne trouvent pas ne
trouvent pas quelqu'un au téléphone ils
ont besoin de d'exprimer leur demande
maintenant on passe par ces plateformes
par exemple madame est donc donné
l'exemple de ma prime
ou les gens sont dans des grandes
difficultés n'ont pas pu être
remboursées ou non pas eu leur
subventions enfin c'est un exemple vous
savez les passeports les cartes
d'identité
plus de 2000 maisons France services
c'est le nom de ces maisons et il dit
qu'il y a 99% des Français qui vivent à
moins de 30 minutes de ces maisons c'est
pas suffisant pour vous vous
reconnaissez pas un effort de la part du
gouvernement il y a un effort mais il
faut en faire davantage même
des gens instruits
éduquer et parfois ont du mal à accéder
à ses services publics ou sinon on
reçoit pas de réponse aussi on a ça
aussi bon merci Alex à tout à l'heure
dans le club on va parler d'immigration
on en parlait tout à l'heure mais c'est
aussi l'actualité dans nos régions avec
la presse régionale et les télés locales
on va à Rennes on retrouve Stéphane
Besnier bonjour Stéphane merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur de
l'information de TV Rennes Stéphane on
va revenir avec vous sur une affaire qui
dure depuis plusieurs semaines du côté
Bruce c'est pas très loin de Rennes
l'installation d'un centre d'accueil
pour demandeur d'asile qui fait couler
beaucoup d'encre
oui c'est vrai c'est un dossier qui se
joue aujourd'hui un peu en trois dates
vous l'avez rappelé ce fameux cada à
défrayé un peu la chronique qui est
d'ailleurs je poserai une question
madame la sénatrice dans un instant mais
le 22 mai dernier en conseil municipal
le maire de Bruz Philippe salmon annonce
l'implantation future d'un cadavre alors
tout de suite le maire se dit un peu
surpris même selon ces termes abasourdi
car il n'y a pas eu vraiment de
préparation dans ce dossier on a très
vite ciblé un terrain d'État entre à la
fois la gare de Bruz mais également des
terrains militaires et ceux qui posent
réellement problème c'est la salubrité
directement de ce terrain avec des
hydrocarbures avec des métaux lourds
donc il y a eu une levée de boucliers
très vite on conseille municipal le
maire de Bruay a dit oui bien évidemment
et favorable à l'accueil de réfugiés et
de demandeurs utile mais pas n'importe
où et ce qui a fait rebondir un petit
peu le dossier c'est ce terrain et jeudi
dernier et bien para SMS le maire
Philippe salmon a appris de la
préfecture de région que l'idée était
abandonné il y a une réunion publique
jeudi soir salle bagnole à Bruges devant
une centaine de personnes tous essaient
de dire oui à une solution mais une
solution viable alors en début de
semaine va s'ouvrir à Montgermont là
nous sommes à l'ouest de Rennes et une
dizaine de kilomètres un ancien hôtel
qui va pouvoir accueillir et bien pour
l'instant un sas pour accueillir ces
réfugiés et demandeurs d'asile alors
c'est la crise vanza moi j'ai une
question vraiment à vous demander bien
évidemment oui pour l'accueil mais
l'État ne gagnerait-il pas à préparer un
peu mieux ces dossiers pour amener
vraiment quelque chose de plausible pour
ces populations de venir
oui qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
plausible d'abord
mais déjà un dossier un peu plus mieux
ficelé parce que l'on a on a vraiment vu
que le dossier semblait vraiment mal
préparé et que l'endroit qui a été donné
n'avait pratiquement pas de chance
d'aboutir
moi d'abord je suis pas au gouvernement
je vous dirai à la oui j'ai pas vu le
dossier je n'en sais rien mais d'un côté
on veut donner de Paris une image à la
Émilie in Parisse n'est ce pas voilà la
couture le café les croissants etc on a
envoyé les sans-abris et les et les
immigrés en province pour que pendant
les Jeux Olympiques on ne voit rien on
est une image je vais lancer cette
décision de répartir les mouvements une
image retouchée de Paris et de l'autre
côté et il est peut-être je sais pas si
les dossiers sont préparés ou pas
préparé en tout cas l'accueille
l'accueil en région et de plus en plus
difficile alors c'est il y a donc un
problème quelque part vous ne peut pas
dire voilà les dossiers sont mal ficelés
mais à un moment il faut se dire que si
on veut l'intégration des immigrés il
faut les accueillir et les accueillir
c'est aussi les loger pendant le temps
où il font leur demande d'asile et on ne
peut pas vous faites parce que les
populations locales elles sont pas
toujours favorables à l'accueil de ces
demandeurs d'asile
des tensions oui mais il faut faire de
la pédagogie il faut arrêter du matin au
soir dans certaines chaînes de
télévision de de dire que l'immigration
est mauvaise pour la France et que les
délinquants sont des immigrés etc je
vais pas entrer dans les détails mais
c'est quand même le serpent qui se mord
la queue qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors on
peut on les veut pas à Paris on peut pas
les loger ils sont dans la rue donc les
populations les rejets davantage quand
on trouve des des sans logement devant
sa porte
il faut pas restreindre l'immigration
est-ce qu'il faut pas se dire qu'il faut
qu'on accueille moins pour accueillir
mieux écouter si c'est possible
peut-être on l'aurait déjà fait vous
savez l'immigration on peut pas
l'arrêter comme ça vous fermez les
frontières les immigrés qui sont
déterminés qui se battent pour vivre et
qui sont dans la misère en état de
guerre feront tout pour arrêter pour
pardon pour rentrer alors vous savez moi
je suis historienne l'histoire est faite
d'immigration et il y a des vagues
d'immigration ça c'est vrai aussi mais
on peut pas les arrêter est-ce qu'on
peut arrêter
un ami on a beau oui les passeurs
étaient déjà bien sûr ils sont coupables
et pas ça mais quand on regarde de près
l'histoire il y a pas d'immigration sans
pasteur alors écoutez qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous réponds il faut faire
de la pédagogie c'est pas ça bien sûr il
faut les sanctionner mais il faut faire
aussi de la pédagogie pour dire aux
populations que les immigrés il faut
qu'il s'installe quelque part et qu'on
voit et le l'histoire de de Monsieur
Manouchian montre bien que on peut être
français de venir se battre pour la
France
se battre pour la France même quand on
est à patride étranger donc arrêtons
quand même de remplir la tête des gens
en période de crise et d'inflation et de
colère et de colère vous avez parlé on a
parlé des forces de l'ordre il y a une
colère quand même de la population avec
avec ces manifestations contre
l'allongement de l'âge de la retraite
etc cette colère elle est intériorisée
on peut pas on peut pas faire fille de
tout ça avoir des réponses
courtes comme ça
extérioriser dans les urnes avec un
vôtre rassemblement national oui
43% des Français disent qu'ils ont voté
au moins une fois Rennes
oui en période de crise on se tourne
vers ceux qui n'ont jamais gouverné en
espérant que ça ira mieux on va
remercier Stéphane benier merci beaucoup
Stéphane d'avoir été
merci d'avoir été avec nous un dernier
mot estherban Bassard vous êtes
sénatrice de Paris vous représentez non
je vais aller quitter le Sénat oui
qu'est-ce que vous retenez du Sénat vous
en avez été une figure écoutez une belle
expérience beaucoup de combat et une
ambiance feutrée mais
pas moi disons dur et moi je viens de
l'université pour moi ça a été
vraiment pas seulement une belle
expérience mais aussi j'ai appris la
cruauté de la politique
on va se fitter sur ces mots merci
beaucoup Esther Benbassa merci
cette première demi-heure dans 20
minutes dans le classe du territoire on
va parler des états généraux de la
droite les républicains réunis ce
week-end pour entamer leur
reconstruction y était vous verrez le
reportage et puis les républicains
peuvent-ils se passer d'un accord avec
Emmanuel Macron ce sera le débat du club
dans 20 minutes d'abord on accueille
notre prochaine invité Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan nous rejoint